JEN PERSON: Welcome to Getting
Started with Artifact Registry.
In this video series,
I'm going to walk you
through setting
up some common use
cases for Artifact Registry.
But before I get into
how to get started,
it'd probably make sense to tell
you what Artifact Registry is.
Artifact Registry manages your
container images and language
packages while integrating with
Cloud's Build, Test, and Deploy
suite and third
party CI/CD systems.
If you're familiar with
Container Registry,
you're thinking Artifact
Registry sure sounds similar,
and you're right.
Artifact Registry is
the next generation
of Container Registry.
Container Registry has
provided a single place
for your team to
manage docker images,
perform vulnerability
analysis, and decide
who can access what with
fine-grained access control.
Existing CI/CD
integrations let you
set up fully automated Docker
pipelines to get fast feedback.
In an effort to build upon
this powerful foundation,
Google Cloud created
Artifact Registry.
Artifact registry offers even
more fine-grained permissions,
allowing you to control access
at the project or registry
level.
You can create multiple
regional repositories
within a single
Google Cloud project
you can create multiple
repos under a project
with independent
registry-specific permissions.
So you have control over
where artifacts are stored
and who can access them.
After hearing about
Artifact Registry,
I bet you can't
wait to get started.
Let's walk through the steps
using a hypothetical company
I've created, Drayne.
Drayne is autonomous,
artificially intelligent,
voice-enabled plumbing
for the modern home.
I'll make Drayne part
of your pipeline using
Artifact Registry in
the software pipeline.
Now.
If you don't think that's
a little bit of money,
this is going to be a
long video series for you.
You can create a new repository,
list existing repositories,
and configure access controls
through the GFP console
or through the gcloud
command-line tool.
Today, I'm using gcloud.
to find out about setting up the
G Cloud CLI check out the guide
link below.
All right, let's get started.
First, you'll need a
Google Cloud project
with billing enabled.
You can use an existing
project or create a new one.
Next, enable the Artifact
Registry API in the console,
then open a new terminal window.
To create a new repository,
type your gcloud command
in this format where
repository is the name
of your new repository.
Format is the repository
format, which is either
Docker, Maven, or NPM.
Location is the regional
or multi-regional location
for the repository.
And you can leave aside if
you set a default location.
And description is an optional
description of the repository.
Including the async
flag causes the command
to return immediately without
waiting for the operation
in progress to complete.
So for example, here's a
command from my Drayne app.
My repository is called Drayne
Pipe, it's a Docker container,
the Location I've
chosen is US Central-1,
And I've included
this description
so I can easily track the
contents of my repositories.
And here, is the results.
To view a list of
repositories, you'll
want to run this command, where
project is the Project ID.
If you don't include this flag,
then the current or default
project is used.
Use the Location flag
to view repositories
from a specific location.
You can also use Location
All to list repositories
across all locations.
If you leave out
the location flag,
the command uses
the default location
if a default is configured.
And if there isn't
a default location,
leaving out this flag,
lists repositories
across all locations.
So when I run the command
without a project or location,
I'm shown my current
project here.
As you can see, creating and
viewing your repositories
is super simple.
But before you dive headlong
into Artifact Registry,
you have one very important
consideration, security.
If you currently use
any GCP products,
you're probably at
least somewhat familiar
with the roles associated
with access controls.
The most basic rules are
owner, editor, and viewer.
And although you can use these
primitive project-wide owner,
editor, and viewer roles to
grant access to repositories,
using specific
Artifact Registry roles
enables you to apply the
security principle of least
privilege so that users
and service accounts only
have access to the
permissions that are required.
For example, the
artifactregistry.reader role
allows a user to view
and get artifacts
just from a specific
project's repositories.
Whereas the roles/reader
role allows the user
to view and get any existing
resources and data from all
Cloud components of the project.
To grant a permission
for a user,
naturally you grant a role
that includes that permission.
Where appropriate you should
use the Artifact Registry
roles to control access to
your repositories, rather
than those project-wide roles.
You can grant these Artifact
Registry roles, Reader, Writer,
Repository Administrator,
and Administrator.
Let's grants some roles
for the repository
we just made for my completely
fake company, Drayne.
Again, I'm using the gcloud
CLI because it rocks.
To add roles via the CLI,
need to create a reference
policy file named policy.yaml.
In that file, I start
with the bindings key,
then I name a role,
and list members.
Here is a more complete
reference policy example.
Notice I have an owner for the
whole project and then Artifact
Registry specific roles.
For reader, you can
see there is a service
account with read privileges
and a specific user with read
privileges.
You can find a complete
reference template
in the documentation,
which contains more example
user and service account names.
To add a team
member to a project
and grant them an
Artifact Registry role,
I add them to the policy file.
Then, from the command
line, I run this command,
passing the name of the project
and the path to my .yaml file.
To get the currently
configured policy,
I run gcloud project's
get-iam-policy, passing
the name of the project.
And there you have it,
you're ready to create
a new repository, list
existing repositories,
and configure access controls
for Artifact Registry.
But there's so much more to
know about Artifact Registry.
Stay tuned for future
episodes of Getting
Started with Artifact Registry.
And to see a guide on these
tasks and so much more,
check out the documentation.
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]